I think I'm losing my mind how long have
we been here how long has it been since
I ate that wing we've been here for
three days
Oh God
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Maisie Williams
she's an Emmy nominated actress you know
as Arya Stark in Game of Thrones she's
also a tech entrepreneur an animal
activist but how was she fair today
against some of the spiciest vegan
snacks in the history of the world we'll
find out today Maisie Williams welcome
to the show thank you for having me I'm
very excited you're excited no I'm
terrified I can see it a little bit but
let me calm you down just a bit how do
you handle your heat my stepdad actually
one time at Christmas thought would be a
good idea for us all to have like a
little spoonful of hot sauce and I just
remember like wanting to put the hot hot
sauce the milk in my ears where it was
like burning so much well are you ready
to relive some holiday memories oh yeah
I can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay no problem now
[Music]
so you come to us from the big budget
world of HBO but I know that YouTube has
a very special place in your heart you
grew up on vloggers like jenna Marbles
and Daily Grace
are you still notification squad or do
you find yourself watching less YouTube
these days no I'm still there every
Wednesday / Thursday for jenna Marbles
it's really sad because her dogs are
getting older now and I've watched
marble-like grow up and you know I'm
gonna it's gonna be painful when that
day comes right but yeah I know I'm
still in for her channel on this channel
called robot it's fun up tea and that's
like where I'm at you have good taste
Maisie thanks can you tell us what it
was like to shoot with binging with
babish she's a friend of ours I'm shot
with him a couple times and I find it
challenging because you're working off
that monitor and then it's framed up
like this I'm always going like opposite
my instincts and reaching out of the
frame and everything yeah and he's like
such a pro at it now cuz like his setup
and it's his house and he's like very
chill about it I'm like yeah it's still
kind of nerve-wracking when there's a
camera on you anyway and then you've got
a like try and do all these technical
things and yeah it was like a little
overwhelming but I just wanted some good
food I honestly just kept messaging
people I was like messaging Bon Appetit
and I was like messaging him and I was
like does anyone have any food I'm in
New York and I'm really hungry yeah and
he pulled through and we ate some bread
[Music]
that wasn't as bad as the one before
we're playing mind games with you over
here okay what happens if you like gets
in my throat and then like half and it's
like aggressive that would be that's
good we'll put some like deep bass sound
effect yeah maybe hit you with a fast
zoom and shake the camera okay okay cool
no I'm looking forward to save that one
up yeah this is true that you almost
missed your game of Thrones audition
because you didn't want to miss a class
trip to the pig farm yeah that's true
when mom was like really put her foot
down and I was like kind of mad about it
just really wanted to go on that school
trip but you know I wouldn't be here
today
good then you didn't yeah he wouldn't
have want me on the show if I'd have
gone to that pig farm maybe we would
have you gotta get that girl from the
field trip her hyenas misunderstood I
know that you worked closely with them
when you were doing heatstroke day of
Africa but the guy who was like handling
them and like training them he was very
clear that like you can't really train a
hyena and like they are wild animals and
they will do what they want to do and
you have to really respect them and so
like we tried our best to do that you
know we said please and thank you and
yeah no but they're incredible animals
unlike very neck heavy and I can play
[Music]
well as you'd expect from a show that's
racked up more than 150 Emmy nominations
and broken almost every ratings record
Game of Thrones it's like the most
fabled show on the Internet so here we
went a fact check some of the rumors
that are swirling around in cyberspace
okay factored fiction Game of Thrones
writers would prank the cast by handing
out fake scripts involving their deaths
and then sometimes let the joke play out
for weeks before come and clean yeah
that's true they did that they I think
they told Alfie Allen that he was killed
by bran in like a really anticlimactic
way but then they didn't tell Isaac that
they were doing the joke so then he
texts Isaac like it's cool about that
you know and then Isaac was like I don't
know what you're talking about and then
it all you know they did another one on
Kent Harrington where they said that he
got like really aggressively mold on the
face and he was gonna have like a huge
disfigurement on his beautiful
you know chiseled jaw and that was quite
[Music]
true that when Queen Elizabeth visited
you guys on set she refused to sit in
the Iron Throne because of an esoteric
rule barring her from sitting on a
foreign seat of state yeah I mean she
didn't necessarily like refused no one
said sit on that chair because it's
gonna be funny we all just sort of
smiles and were like is she gonna do it
you know everyone's like that and um
yeah she sort of looked to it and said
that doesn't look very comfy comfortable
she wants that coma faked on this Queen
Elizabeth and then finally is it true
that you're right-handed but did most of
the sword work left-handed to be true to
the original novels yes that is true
that was 12 year old me being I don't
know a feminist I guess yeah no I just
like seen on the internet cuz I wasn't
most exciting thing that ever happened
to me so I'd read everything about Game
of Thrones online and everyone was like
oh that horse is supposed to be black
not white and like you know getting
really upset about the most trivial
things so I was like cus I'm gonna have
to do this left-handed and at the
beginning it was like very exciting but
I'd always come into the choreography
and they'd start teaching it to me and
I'd be like you've done it
and it haven't you and they'd be like
yeah we did and I'm like well you gonna
have to change it all I'll be back at
noon mm-hmm no I doesn't like that
I wish I was though travelled me like
that that would have been funnier are
these getting hotter I don't seem like
they're getting hotter well maybe it's a
psychological thing mm-hmm
I'll be trapped so I want to take a wing
to talk about the launch of dayz which
as I understand as a talent discovery
app designed to help artists collaborate
yeah it's for people who are
up-and-coming and like you have a great
idea but you just don't have the
contacts with people that can help you
do that because it's all about
collaboration you know like it's me and
you on camera right now but there's like
15 other people in this job so it's
basically a platform where it's really
targeted towards um like the skill set
that you have and the discovery for that
I thought it was interesting that you
decided on the app to not use like
upvotes and likes as someone who has
your unique perspective someone of your
age do you find that the ill effects of
social media and young people are they
overstated or understated in your
opinion I don't think is either I just
think that it's not taken as seriously
as it needs to be people are either
talking about it like it's awful we
should get rid of all of it and like
they hate the internet and like hate
what it's doing to their children or
people talk about it like Oh kids are so
stupid that they think that this is like
you know and no one's actually just
taking it seriously enough and
understanding that it's not gonna go
away but we just need to like figure it
out I'm like excited now I feel like I'm
gonna kill this you are killing it you
know people say that after four wings
sometimes yeah
oh okay that was quite hot I amazing we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that grammar we do a deep
dive on our guests Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context I'm really excited to see what
you chose all right well you know it's
season ten we're doing a big we have a
monitor now we've retired the laps oh my
gosh
cool here you are with a plays well with
others t-shirt at comic-con it really
sad about it yeah do you know what it is
so someone at comic-con they like do
questions for them from the audience and
someone like stood a pose like I have a
question I just want to give you my
shirt and the reason why I'm frowning so
hard is because their little area on the
because I've got like a real harsh brown
line and they even drew it on on the
t-shirt and so I was like look she's got
the frown line so that's why I'm
frowning
what's the re s star catchphrase like
the things we know today and they're
like what's your name one time this
person goes what's your name and I was
like amazing Williams and they went no
and I was like oh [ __ ] yeah sorry I have
no name up next here you are at
Wimbledon giving a hug to Ellen
DeGeneres : yeah that happened
why was Ellen there I mean we're in the
Royal Box I guess you like got to have
Alan in the Royal Box
everyone's like on their best behavior
and light but they're also like plying
you with pens so you're like getting
more and more drunk but like you have to
keep it together and be like really
serious and then like it got to like the
end of the day and like it was then that
the TV cameras were like who do we have
in the Royal Box today and they were
like Maisie Williams and I was like
whatever whatever I was dealing at
Wimbledon who didn't come on
[Music]
okay that's not very nice
okay he's gonna get hot now isn't it you
would get real
oh no I'm sad put some bass on that okay
I just need to know yeah yeah hit that
oat milk hit that oat milk so we've
talked a lot about the behind the scenes
of Game of Thrones but we should talk
about the broader cultural impact
because it's a show that's dominated
water-cooler conversations for close to
a decade yeah what was your reaction
when Drake said shout out to Arya Stark
for putting in that work last week at
the Billboard Music Awards it was like
wow it's really exciting but like I
wasn't that so I was like afterwards in
my room like she was never quite as cool
like I wish I was there to be like
do you feel like Taylor Swift's look
what you made me do is a good musical
interpretation of arias kill list
absolutely that came out and I thought
I'm relevant I know but that's crazy it
must be surreal I know I know that one
of the biggest pop stars in the world
would put together an album that was
basically inspired by binge watching
Game of Thrones yeah
for sure it was cool I love that album
as well it was like a real turn for her
you know she like did that thing that
pops I'll stay here anyway and then in
2011 the u.s. Social Security
Administration reported that aria is the
fastest growing baby name for girls is
that a badge of honour for you it is
that's cool that's really cool I think
if I wasn't on the show well yeah if I
wasn't on the show it would be like a
name that I'd think of for my child
because it's like there she's such a
great character be weird if I did it now
though you're like this is aria
mrs. Sansa made my children
[Music]
open go-for-broke repeat okay let's do
it
they just creep darling that's the other
thing that you have to worry about
oh no and
how many days you have to go until you
do another episode well it's funny that
you ask that you know because we are
opportunists here at hot ones you know
like wherever the thing happens we chase
that thing and they pop up this set
wherever full of them so for example we
shot yesterday with Ashton Kutcher do
you are you like do you have to go to
the doctor's make sure you don't have we
should again on Friday and then the
following Tuesday it just stacks
hopefully I'll make it so last season I
got a crash course in cockney rhyming
slang from Idris Elba so now that you're
here I'm hoping that you can add some
Bristol isms to my growing arsenal
do people in Bristol like do locals call
it brizl or would that be like a New
Yorker callin New York the Big Apple
yeah they don't really do that right I
never met anyone that's done that maybe
there's like a weird portion of Bristol
that do that I couldn't believe that but
I've never really heard want to actually
do that what does it mean to say these
wings are gert lush oh just means that
they're really good they say it right
yeah got last gert lush I mean I love
that we're doing this on this side like
putting breasts on them up on hot ones
right yeah she just messaged my family
group chat we're going away for
Christmas and I just like put like it's
gonna be good luck Arkadiy Arkadiy you
ever heard that but you know like when
you say a word over and over again and
then you're like that doesn't sound like
a word anymore though you're naughty
Arkadiy Arkadiy in that sweatshirt oh oh
that means I did not
[Music]
that means I didn't I didn't Cheryl I
didn't barrel that one up
like hawk at hey I guess it's kind of
like look at him hard at he but you say
like our key because it's like flying
marker yeah just like that just like
that you know say that in London and
they'll go wow he is a wonder
all right Maisie you know the show this
is the bomb
[Music]
I'm really proud of myself by the way
you're killing it
you're doing great oh it's hard I just
got a little oh okay
I just wanted to help I don't know if
that's better or worse but I'm not
cheering that donkey as bad it's still
bad it's bad
Oh God mmm I think I really like dodged
a bullet there though it's just follow
at home and just risk choking well let's
see how this goes okay you know yeah we
put the cart in front of the horse here
sometimes Oh the build okay but maybe it
is maybe that's little you know I think
I got it Russell oh it sucks oh it's
like it's like coming from within yeah
it's like actually no it's good yeah I
know I think it was just like oh is it
true that for most of your life you
thought that graham crackers were called
cram crackers yeah because you guys cool
gram gram gram oh yeah so I thought they
were just called cram crackers for the
uninitiated why is the cream they have
one that's not covered at all
yeah DOM is fast on the draw here Dex
it's Christmastime right here like yeah
right here with you okay but the
uninitiated why is the Great British
Bake Off the best cooking show on TV Oh
cuz marry Barry but now it's Prue
there's no offense to prove like poor
girl remember Mary was just you know she
was so sassy you know like she really
just like when Paul was being a beber
dick just was like you know we like that
yeah why are we crying over here is
cauliflower
Oh crying I don't know so when someone
when someone when someone does
cauliflower and oat milk do you do
cauliflower dan Oh milk cauliflower oat
milk whatever that gas goes what that's
Nagaland and then you know and the
lead-up to Game of Thrones Season eight
there are so many Game of Thrones food
products from the Drakkar yes burger at
Shake Shack to these Oreos that are
stamped with the stark sign Oh God
people go to but when you order a coffee
sometimes they'll put like you know a
nice like your face well I don't have
that but like you know a thing yeah yeah
people do things like that a lot but
I've never had any of the things that
you said I think I'm losing my mind how
long have we been here
like how long has it been since I ate
that wing it's we've been here for three
days
Oh God
[Music]
shivering no I don't know what it is I
don't know what's happening to me
I don't do it oh it's a bit red there
it's just sucks on every side okay I'm
sorry
okay I mean okay take your time take
your time
okay not right
banded rip it yeah totally just follow
it at home at this point I did the rest
of them without swallowing the hole that
they've had so much like chili on that
now it's just like don't put more chili
on your lips
right you once said that if you had a
career and dance that you would leave
acting is that still true yeah I just I
would owe every I would do both I would
never like do it over acting anymore
like oh I love it
but like having something that you
really love as a hobby while still doing
something that you love for a career is
like a win-win because sometimes if you
make your tobe a career then like you
can start to hate it because it's like
that's what you know your brain does
because it's annoying was the dance
party as sophie Turner and Joe Jonas is
wedding up to standard I'm sure that
that was part of your responsibilities
on the maid of honor checklist it was
quite the party Diplo came in
Spahn the decks have Diplo at your
wedding that's like that's the hack
apparently was supposed to be at
Glastonbury and he didn't go cuz he came
to the wedding
Wow and that's the tea
[Music]
all right no we're here we're here we're
here which is a good thing you did know
law you know I wanna do the dab
you don't have to do the death no I
should
yeah be careful wait I just I can't you
think straight that's fine it's my
engineering the bunny thing again for
the first for the second time in your
life yeah this is like no joke yeah you
told me it was more for that benefit yes
it's no joke
as someone who's seen the show watches
the show is it what you thought it would
be in terms of spice is a hotter than
you thought it would be is it not as hot
as he thought it would be you know the
freaky flavors are a real nice touch
because I thought it was very nice touch
that makes it you know it's like calms
your nerves as you like go into it that
was like something I didn't expect by
I'm grateful for but you know coming
into these last four wings here where it
becomes a different experience yeah okay
sorry is this better for camera here bro
what up bro careful though yeah it is so
it sneaks up on you yet it does our old
last tab Oh dick yeah smart I'm gonna
start doing that can I do that I'm dip
it dip it okay and not kid like you know
mentally feel like it's ketchup but it's
not do you hear me I'm like I feel like
I've got like like there everything's
swollen okay yep I hope no one gives me
[ __ ] for that come on that's fine that's
a big death it's very quiet okay
no I don't oh oh no I feel like we're
about to jump yeah and then I jumped and
you just like you just went and I'm like
oh sorry okay
[Music]
well I'll come home oh no I mean all
right Maisie Williams the bells they're
bringing here on our battle against the
wings of death but we just have one more
obstacle before we get you out of here
we'd be remiss not to mention your BFF
and co-star sophie Turner I know that
you guys were attached at the hip for
the last 10 years on set even getting
matching tattoos to commemorate the day
that you guys got your roles together it
is so beautiful so when I was here and
so do I which is why I'd like you to
look into this camera in either try to
convince sophie turner that hot ones is
a good idea
Oh either persuader or dissuade her from
doing the show depending on how you're
feeling right now we've never eaten hot
food together so I don't know how you're
gonna do it this so I want you to come
and do hot ones I'm calling you out
come do hot work do hot ones and then
like maybe I'll be better than you but
probably not well you know what you've
gone to the top of the mountain today
Maisie Williams you are nervous the red
flag that's that's they waved a red flag
when someone's a champion
Yeah right just let it go Moisture
everywhere it's not chicken and look at
you at the end of the line and now there
is nothing left to do but roll out the
red carpet for you I wanna do it again
that was so fun this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life oh nothing
really just eating hot food
happy holidays everybody okay hug hi tag
I'm on hot ones no that's right I think
I got a milk moustache that's good for
the pig hey what's going on hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans checking in to
say if you do not have plans on November
second or third come out to complex
Kanban Beach hot ones will be bringing
it for our fourth straight year doing a
live episode with the baby the first we
feast food zone I'll be making the
rounds taking pictures slinging hot
sauce you don't want to miss it again
that's November 2nd and 3rd in Long
Beach California hot ones round 4 baby
[Music]